Okay.
Some people think my music
is dope.
Some people see me as, like,
this Satanic devil.
But me?
When I was a kid,
my sexuality was just, like,
the elephant in the room.
I started getting like bad,
like, anxiety attacks.
On God...
Coming out was
very important to progress.
Just put out
"Old Town Road"...
Let me hit y’all back
a year from now.
We gon' see
where I'm at.
My mind is hardwired
since a kid,
when you fuck up, you have
to quit the whole thing.
I feel like there's
something brewing
that's gonna be so amazing.
I trust that feeling.
I'm not, like, able to be
100 percent
around, like,
family members.
I feel like there's
a lot of things
that people may want to say,
but don't.
I'm always just trying
to challenge the way
my family, like, looks
at things.
I'm gonna teach my nephews
to not be homophobic.
-Hey. Hey, y'all.
-What?
Don't...
don't be homophobic.
Okay...
So many queer people
are making these huge
strides but it's a fight.
Hello, family.
It's like, crazy to walk out
in front of like,
both sides of your family
in, like, this little skirt.
I’m like: what's up, Dad?
There's still
parts of myself
that I'm learning to accept.
But we're getting closer.